you won't find it in Apple's claims or
marketing videos but it's new MacBook is
a time machine you see by looking
directly at it it teleports you into the
future of the laptop where's Doc Brown
and all those flying cars anyway as I
was saying with its new MacBook Apple
has imagined that laptops will be
reduced to just a thin screen a keyboard
and a magical piece of touch-sensitive
glass oh and just one port because in
the future nearly everything is wireless
the problem we're not living in the
future yet I mean do you see anybody
else here also I speak for the people of
the future when I say that we don't want
design to deprive us of battery life and
speed and certainly not for $1,300
unless $1,300 is really cheap in the
future then I'm ok with it oh but this
design can we just talk about for a
second how compact and drop-dead
gorgeous this laptop is did I'd say
laptop because it looks more like a
showpiece it can even out your jewelry
though as nice as that new mirrored
Apple logo is for checking if you have
something in your teeth it can easily
scratch other than that the two-pound
all-metal machine really does feel quite
sturdy which is a good thing since
you'll really want to carry this thing
around a lot
adding to that beauty is this beautiful
12-inch Retina display with the crazy
high-resolution display photos look like
they were painted on and even boring
text is nice to read now when I go back
to my errors lower resolution screen
everything looks pixelated but the new
force touch trackpad is my favorite part
of the laptop when the computer is off
the piece of glass does not press down
when it's on sensors measure the
pressure you're putting on it a quick
vibration and sound makes it feel like
you're clicking there are different
pressure levels too for instance when
you press hard on a word it looks up the
definition the keyboard is also
different though not necessarily better
because the panel is so much thinner the
keys had to be shorter there's still
plenty wide and have a good amount of
bounds to them but I really did miss the
height and comfort of my Ayers keys
but that's not the worst of the
sacrifices let me introduce you to my
new enemy the MacBooks single USB type-c
port one day this is gonna be amazing
it has bi-directional power that means
the laptop can charge while being
connected to peripherals like monitors
and phones but living with one port one
that doesn't work with much yet is
painful the best answer is this $80.00
dongle with it you can charge the laptop
plug in a USB device and even a monitor
forget the dongle at home and all you
can really do is cry and whatever you do
don't leave the charger at home either
the laptop only gets seven hours of
usage about four hours less than my
13-inch MacBook Air yeah it turns out
I'm full of complaints in the future
and here's another the laptop isn't even
as fast as my air
it isn't slow when surfing the web or
doing regular work but with more
processor intensive tasks like managing
lots of open apps it does get sluggish
the MacBook has so much of what I want
in the laptop of the future the right
screen and trackpad in a stunning
portable design as more companies adopt
USB type-c I'll get over that gripe but
I'm still gonna want more speed and
battery life that means I'm really happy
in the present and with my more
affordable MacBook Air I'll come back
here eventually they're just better not
be any $80 dongles when I get here